Ось так виглядає COVID-сертифікат. Він називається цифровим і при цьому на … папері.
Це звичайний аркуш А-4. Вказано, яка країна ЄС видала. У даному випадку - Німеччина.
Відповідно мова німецька з перекладом на англійську.
Тут зазначено дату щеплення, яка вакцина, хто виробник.
Просто головний елемент цього паперу - ось цей QR-код.
Його сканують в аеропортах, на вокзалах та інших місцях і тим самим перевіряють,
чи сертифікат не підроблений. Тож винахідливим українцям просто змінити
ім’я та дату народження і видати чужий сертифікат за свій - не вийде.
Крім того, щоб не носити цей аркуш постійно з собою, код можна відсканувати
спеціальним додатком. Кожна країна ЄС створила свій застосунок.
У Німеччині, приміром, це CovPass і Corona-Warn-App. Тут видно,
коли було зроблено останнє щеплення та особисті дані власника.
Термін дії сертифікатів після повної вакцинації - один рік.
Окрім першого виду сертифікату, який підтверджує вакцинацію проти коронавірусу, є ще два.
Про негативний тест та про одужання від COVID-19.
Відповідно вони видаються після актуального тесту або одужання.
Сертифікат негативного тесту видаватимуть після ПЛР-тесту або тесту на антиген.
Тести ж на антитіла поки не будуть основою для видачі сертифікату.
Підтвердження одужання можна отримати лише після позитивного ПЛР-тесту на коронавірус.
При цьому сертифікат видаватимуть не раніше, ніж через 11 днів після позитивного тесту.
Діятиме документ 180 днів.
Загалом усі три види сертифікатів визнає 31 країна.
Це 27 держав ЄС, а також Ісландія, Ліхтенштейн, Норвегія та Швейцарія,
які не входять до Євросоюзу, але є частиною Шенгенської зони.
Більшість із них ще раніше почали видавати цифрові свідоцтва.
За даними Єврокомісії, сім країн ще не приєдналися до єдиної системи перевірки сертифікатів,
але технічно готові до цього. У них є час до 12 серпня, щоб остаточно
впровадити ці сертифікати. Платити за ковідні свідоцтва не треба.
Українці, які мають посвідку на проживання у ЄС, можуть отримувати
цифрові COVID-сертифікати ЄС, як і решта громадян Євросоюзу.
Безкоштовно і без жодних обмежень.
Теоретично отримати європейський сертифікат також можуть і громадяни інших держав,
у тому числі й України. Для цього потрібно на кордоні надати
підтвердження про повну вакцинацію. Які саме документи для цього підтвердження
визнаються і де отримати сертифікат - вирішує кожна держава ЄС на свій розсуд.
Крім того, ЄС визнаватиме і ковідні сертифікати інших держав,
але ці документи мають бути сумісними з європейськими.
Київ наразі веде переговори з Брюсселем про визнання сертифікатів ще з квітня.
Рішення поки немає, але є надія, що до кінця літа таки вдасться узгодити усі питання з ЄС.
Лише з 1 липня розпочалося бета-тестування українських цифрових
свідоцтв вакцинації. Сертифікат можна буде отримати в мобільному додатку
та на порталі "Дія", а з часом - і в сімейного лікаря.
У першу чергу визнаються зареєстровані у ЄС вакцини. Їх чотири:
BioNTech/Pfizer, Moderna, AstraZeneca та Johnson & Johnson.
Крім того, у Єврокомісії уточнюють, що також підійдуть ці чотири вакцини,
навіть якщо вони вироблені на потужностях, не сертифікованих європейським регулятором.
Це означає, що вакцина від AstraZeneca, яка виробляється у Південній Кореї
і якою щеплюють в Україні, теж визнається.
А от Covishield, що є індійським аналогом AstraZeneca і широко використовується в Україні,
вважається окремою вакциною. Поки що вона не зареєстрована
для допуску на ринок ЄС. Але з іншого боку Всесвітня організація охорони здоров'я
рекомендує Covishield, а також китайські Sinovac і Sinopharm,
якими теж щеплюють в Україні, до використання в умовах надзвичайної ситуації.
Чи визнавати їх і чи видавати сертифікати - це вже вирішуватиме
кожна держава ЄС самостійно. Тож, є висока вірогідність, що значна частина країн ЄС
визнає ці вакцини й щеплені ними українці зможуть подорожувати до Євросоюзу.
При цьому російська вакцина "Спутник V" досі не отримала схвалення ані від ВООЗ,
ані від європейського регулятора EMA. Це означає, що отримати європейський сертифікат
на основі щеплення "Спутником V" не можна.
Обов'язок носити маски поки що не скасовується і для повністю вакцинованих.
Приміром, у Німеччині, за словами міністра охорони здоров'я ФРН Єнса Шпана,
тим, хто отримав щеплення, маски доведеться носити під час так званого перехідного етапу
- з міркувань солідарності. Крім того, експерти наголошують,
що маски потрібні, допоки щонайменше 55 відсотків населення
не буде повністю вакциновано.
Згідно з прогнозами, до кінця липня близько 52 відсотків дорослого населення Німеччини
буде вакциновано, проте для досягнення колективного імунітету цього поки недостатньо.
Тож, деякі експерти припускають, що носіння масок у громадських місцях
залишиться в силі навіть після пандемії.